Mein Name ist... Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ekrem Özvolle.
Ich bin auf dieser Station aus Arslanarst tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch führen.
Alles in Ordnung für Sie?
Das ist für mich in Ordnung. Ja, bitte schön.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Und als erstes benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten.
Dann können wir weiterführen. Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Laura Lux.
Frau Lux, können Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen
deutlich und langsam buchstabieren?
LV Luxemburg, AVI Ali,
Uvi Ulrich, R.V. Richard, AVI Ali.
Und Nachname ist LV Luxemburg, Uvi Ulrich und X.
X und X, ja super.
Vielen Dank, Frau Lux.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Lux?
Ich bin 29 Jahre alt.
29 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin am 12. April 1996 geboren.
1996.
Vielen Dank.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Lux?
Ich bin 1,65 Meter groß.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
72 Kilo.
Vielen Dank, Frau Lux.
Was für eine Saison ist das, Frau Lux?
Ich bin jetzt bei Ihnen, weil ich seit ungefähr drei Tagen
eine Sehverschlechterung am linken Auge habe.
Seit drei Tagen?
Eine Sehverschlechterung am linken Auge habe.
Mit auch Schmerzen am Auge.
Linken Auge habe.
Okay, ich habe das notiert.
Die Schmerzen plöstigen oder langsam aufgetreten?
Die sind eigentlich zunehmend, haben langsam angefangen
und werden jetzt immer mehr.
Zunehmend.
Linken Auge.
Wie würden Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Dumpfstechende Schmerzen vielleicht?
Insbesondere wenn ich meine Augen bewege?
Ja, insbesondere bewege.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Verlässe oder?
Nein.
Haben Sie eine Farbveränderung bemerkt beim Augen?
Wie beschreiben Sie Sehstörungen?
Sie verschwommen.
Manchmal habe ich auch Flecken, wo ich nicht sehen kann.
Flecken vor Augen?
Ja.
Im Moment können Sie klar sehen oder?
Nicht so klar, nein.
Nicht so klar.
Nur das linke Auge.
Okay, nur das linke Auge.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen beim linken Auge?
Weil 0 kein Schmerzen sind, sehr sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht.
Wie beschreiben Sie auf eine Schmerzklappe?
So 3 bis 4.
3 bis 4.
Haben Sie dagegen ein Medikament eingenommen oder waren Sie schon beim Hausarzt?
Nein.
Ist das das erste Mal?
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch gleichzeitig irgendwelche anderen Probleme?
Ja, mir ist auch aufgefallen, dass ich auf der rechten Armseite und im rechten
Bein kribbeln, Taubheitsgefühl habe und im Bein leicht Schwäche habe.
Rechten Bein, Taubheitsgefühl.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Taubheitsgefühl.
Taubheit ungefähr 3 bis 4 Tagen.
Oh, 3 bis 4 Tagen.
Okay.
Gibt es noch ein Schwächegefühl?
Kraftverlust?
Im rechten Bein.
Ja.
Haben Sie einmal Bewusstsein verloren oder?
Nein.
Gar nicht.
Gibt es noch andere Orte Schmerzen, zum Beispiel Kopfschmerzen oder?
Nein, Kopfschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Manchmal, wenn ich meinen Nacken nach vorne beuge, habe ich stromschlagartige
Schmerzen an der Wirbelsäule.
Stromschlagartige Schmerzen.
Genau.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöser für diese Beschwerden?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Gibt es etwas, das Schmerzen oder Beschwerden verstärkt oder etwas lindert?
Haben Sie nicht, damit?
Frau Lux, haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe keine Fieber, nein.
Keine Fieber.
Haben Sie noch Schweiß, Sterfrost oder Herzrassen?
Keine.
Herzmolken?
Gibt es noch Schlafstörungen?
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Eigentlich schon.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuckern?
Nein.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Besonderheit im Gesicht?
Keine.
Haben Sie Schluckprobleme?
Nein.
Keine.
Gibt es noch eine Asymmetrie?
Nein.
Haben Sie noch eine Konzentrationprobleme?
Wie beschreiben Sie Ihre rechten Arm und rechten Bein?
Schwäche Gefühl?
Ja, es ist eher ein kribbeln, leichtes Taubbeinsgefühl.
Ich habe nicht so viel Kraft in den Armen und den Beinen.
Haben Sie noch einen Kraftverlust?
Schwäche.
Ich kann schon umpacken, aber nicht so stark wie vorher.
Können Sie sich Ihre linkseitige Augenlinde bewegen?
Ja.
Frau Luchs, leiden Sie an irgendeiner Art krümchen Erkrankung?
Nein, gar nicht.
Würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Noch nie.
Haben Sie noch eine Allergie?
Nein.
Keine Allergie.
Und Unverträglichkeit?
Nein, nicht als Justum.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf oder in der Lesterseite Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Kein Medikament.
Frau Luchs, rauchen Sie?
Ich bin nicht Rauchern.
Nicht Rauchern.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr, sehr selten, vielleicht ein oder zwei Mal im Jahr.
Sehr selten.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie noch einmal Drogen probiert?
Nein.
Gar nicht.
Okay.
Sind Sie vorgeimpft?
Ja, ich bin vorgeimpft.
Gegen Corona auch?
Gegen Corona vor zwei Jahren zuletzt.
Vor zwei Jahren, okay.
In der Lesterseite waren Sie im Ausland?
Im Oktober war ich im Ausland.
Im Oktober.
Wo waren Sie?
In Portugal.
Da haben Sie etwas Wichtiges erlebt, oder?
Nein, ich war auf Strandurlaub.
Frau Luchs, gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, also nichts Besonderes.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja.
Vater ist gesund?
Ja, er hat Bluthochdruck.
Unter Kontrolle?
Ja, er ist relativ missvermaßen.
Und die Mutter?
Die Mutter ist auch gesund.
Sie hat eigentlich keine relevanten Erkrankungen.
Okay, super.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Einzelkind.
Frau Luchs, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Lehrerin.
Lehrerin.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein.
Kein Kind?
Okay, Frau Luchs, Sie haben schon gesagt, seit drei Tagen haben Sie eine Sehstörung
beim linken Auge und auch Augenschmerzen und rechtsseitige Muskelschwächung.
Ja, also auch so kribbeln.
Kribbeln, Taubeidgefühl.
Genau, leichte Taubeidsgefühl.
Aber haben Sie vorher keine ähnliche Beschwerden?
Doch, ich habe das schon mal gehabt.
Ich habe das vor acht Monaten schon mal gehabt.
Da habe ich auch dieses Taubeidsgefühl im linken Bein gehabt.
Taubeidsgefühl vor acht Monaten?
Vor acht Monaten im linken Bein.
Das ist aber dann von alleine wieder weggegangen.
Linkenbein.
Damals haben Sie noch eine Sehstörung gehabt?
Nein.
Nur vor acht Monaten nur die Sehstörung im linken Bein gehabt.
Linkenbein, aber keine Sehstörung.
Nein.
Aber vor drei Tagen Sehstörung und rechtsseitige Taubeidsgefühl und Kribbeln.
Haben Sie schon gesagt, dass Ihr Vater Blutdruck hat?
Bluthochdruck, ja.
Haben Sie noch einmal kontrolliert?
Ja, ich habe bei mir den Blutdruck kontrolliert.
Als ich Augenschmerzen hatte.
Das war aber normal.
Das war ungefähr 115 zu 90.
Ja, okay.
Vor drei Tagen Blutdruck wurde gemessen.
Das war noch ganz normal.
Ganz genau.
Erinnern Sie sich, wie war das?
110 zu 90.
Okay.
Ich habe das mitgehalten.
Frau Lux, ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe Angst.
Ich würde gerne wissen, was das ist.
Hab ich eventuell eine sehr, sehr schlimme Erkrankung oder was haben Sie?
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut, dass Sie Angst haben.
Ich möchte noch eine Frage stellen.
Vor acht Monaten haben Sie schon gesagt,
dass Sie ähnliche Beschwerden haben.
Bei Ihrem linken Bein.
Anderes Bein, ganz genau.
Linkes Bein.
Und damals waren Sie beim Hausarzt oder eine Neurologin?
Nein, ich war nicht beim Arzt gewesen.
Das ist von selbst wieder weggegangen später.
Das ist ungefähr nach einer Woche wieder weggegangen.
Wie viel hat das gedauert?
Eine Woche ungefähr.
Eine Woche.
Aber ohne Sehstörungen.
Okay, alles gut.
Okay.
Vielen Dank, Frau Lux.
Ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Haben Sie Fragen?
Nein.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ich werde Ihnen zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Dann ein wenig Blut abnehmen.
Ich habe eine Neurologik.
Neurologik ist eine Konzertsituation.
Ich habe eine CT-Schede.
Okay.
Und eine Frontgen.
Also eine Computerdomographie?
Ja, natürlich.
Dann kommt diese Pumographie an die Forderung.
Sobald Ihre Ergebnisse vorliegen,
bespreche ich meinem Arzt über Ihre Situation.
Dann komme ich Ihnen zurück.
Dann erzähle ich Ihnen Schritt für Schritt.
Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank und bis dann.
Danke schön.
Ich habe eine weitere Methode.
Die Pille.
Danke schön.
Pille.
Haben Sie Schleifschüttungen?
Nein.
Oder Schwindel?
Nein, auch nicht.
Haben Sie Hörschütungen oder Hörminderungen bemerkt?
Nein.
Nur die Störung.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser bemerkt?
Kalt, Expression oder?
Ich habe es nicht bemerkt.
Wie ist Ihre Ernährung?
Gut.
Sind Sie vegetarisch oder so?
Nein, ich bin nicht vegetarisch.
Vegetarisch, okay.
Sind Ihre Taubheitsgefühle oder Kriben progredient zu nehmen?
Ja.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Hautfarbeveränderungen bemerkt?
Nein.
Beschäftigen Sie mit Ihrem Garten oder anderen Hobbys?
Haben Sie ungewöhnliche Hobbys oder neu anfangen?
Nein.
Darf ich?
Haben Sie früher schon einmal gewusst einen Fehler?
Nein, noch nie.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Eine Drehung?
Dann machen wir ein Tatsgespräch.
Bitte schön.
Okay. Darf ich?
Bitte.
Ja.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Ich möchte Ihnen meinen Patienten vorstellen.
Es geht um Laura Lux.
29 Jahre alt, geboren am 12.05.1996.
1,65 Meter groß und 72 Kilo.
Laura Lux stellte sich heute bei uns seit drei Tagen.
Plötzlich aufgetretene zunehmende Sechsstörung.
Sechs Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen sind seit drei Tagen zunehmend.
Und dumpf.
Sie berichtet, dass die Schmerzen keine bestimmten Auslöser haben.
Sie hatte keine Verletzung.
Sie berichtete, dass die Schmerzen vor Augen fliegen.
Die Schmerzen liegen bei 3 bis 4 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Laut Angaben der Patienten,
dass die Patienten seit drei Tagen
die Patienten beim rechten Arm und rechten Bein
kribbeln und taubweiß gefüllt hatten.
Sie klagt über eine Muskelschwäche.
Und weniger Kraftverlust.
Ansonsten ist die Vegetative-Anamnese unauffällig.
Die Fragen nach Fieber,
nach Schweißkeitsschweißaufbruch,
Herzrasen, Herzklopfen, Atemnot,
Engelgefühl,
unauffällig bis auf Schmerzbedingte Schlafstörungen.
Die Anamnese ist unaufällig.
Keine Allergie, keine Unverträglichkeit.
Sie nimmt keine bestimmten Medikamente,
nur eine Pille als Verhortungsmittel.
Bei den Noxen-Anamnese
ist sehr seltener Alkoholkonsum.
Sie wurde vor ca. fünf Monaten vollgeimpft.
Er ist in Portugal gereist.
Bei der Familienanamnese
ergab er Arteriohypathonie.
Die Mutter ist gesund.
Sie ist Einzelkind.
Bei der sozialen Anamnese
ergab sich die Lehrerin
nicht verheiratet.
Sie ist ein Kind.
Aufgrund der Anamnese
habe ich den Verdacht
auf eine kranielle Embolle
wegen Pillebedingte.
Die Patientin hatte vor acht Monaten
ähnliche Beschwerden
wie bei linker Arm und bei linker Bein.
Sie hatte jetzt
linksseitige Sehschmerzen
und Sehstörungen.
Sie hatte Muskelschwäche,
Kraftverlust, Taubheitgefühl,
und eine Sprit.
Als Differenzelldiagnostik kommen
Mutipisklerose und Meningitis.
Warum glauben Sie,
dass es eine Embolle ist
und keine Mutipisklerose?
Ich habe die Frage nach Medikamenten
und Pillebedingte.
Sie hatte das vor acht Monaten
schon mal.
Hat sie eine rezentivierende Embolle?
Ich dachte,
eine kleine Arteriöle oder Venosembolle
könnte sein.
Was passt mehr?
Welche Diagnose passt mehr?
Als Differenzelldiagnostik
dachte ich,
Mutipisklerose könnte sein.
Interkranielle Tumor.
Müssen Sie ausschließen?
Optikglyome oder so etwas.
Sie beschreiben eine Optikusneuritis.
Typische Beschwerden für MS.
Wenn man überlegt,
wegen Mikroembolie,
zuerst links, jetzt rechts,
das passt nicht ganz zusammen.
Ich habe als MS gedacht,
weil die Patientin sehr jung ist.
Bei der Mutter oder meinem Vater
keine ähnlichen Beschwerden.
Deswegen habe ich nicht als erste Option
MS gedacht.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch?
Ich mache die Blutabnahme als Routine.
Ich habe eine Blutbildung,
ein Übrigenprobe bestimmen lassen.
Dann ein CT-Röntgen.
Wie viel CT?
Normal CT.
CT-Schädel.
Eine intrakranielle Pathologie.
Ein Tumor oder Blutung.
Blutung, Embolle,
Verengung oder Verschluss.
Ich werde einen Tumor machen.
Ich werde einen neurologischen Konzil anfordern.
Dann auf jeden Fall
diese Patienten in die Station nehmen.
Dann
eine Völkische Psychologie.
Eine inmechige Überwachung.
Kann man machen, sehr gut.
Was machen Sie im Verlauf?
Was würden Sie machen an Diagnostik bei dieser Patienten,
wenn das CT unauffällig ist?
Wenn das CT unauffällig ist, möchte ich noch
weiter Diagnostik.
Ein Lumbar-Punktion.
Genau.
Damit kann man die Diagnose einer MS bestätigen.
Und was geben wir ihr als Therapie?
Für die MS.
Also einen Schub?
Dann geben wir...
Als Erstes kann ich nicht so gut...
Man braucht hochdosiert Cortison.
Das ist die Erstdiagnose.
Dann gibt man Cortison.
Wenn sich die Diagnose bestätigt hat,
kann man im Verlauf der Wochen und Monate eine Antikörpertherapie machen.
Cortison, Antikörpertherapie, Patientenschulung.
Physikalische Rehabilitation.
Sehr gut.
Ich habe die MS vergessen.
Ich habe die MS-Benehmigung vergessen.
Ich wusste die genannte Frau.
Aber die zwei-teile-Küste oder die eine-teile-Küste
war in der eine-teile-Baine, oder?
Ich habe die MS nicht alles verwendet.
Aber die Augen, die Stimme, die Stimme der Stimme der Stimme.
Das ist eine der Fälle, die wir oft sehen.
Wenn uns so etwas vorbeiführt,
was können wir als Stichwörter in dieser Situation verfolgen?
Wie alt sind wir?
Als Alter natürlich.
Als Junge, als Frau.
Wie alt sind wir?
Die Stimme, die sich wieder hinterführt.
Und schuldig ist, dass dieser Augenproblem viel zwingt.
Diese Augen sehen wir nicht, die Schmerzen z códigoieren.
Da kann man es sagen.
Die Stimme, die sich hinterführt.
Ja, das ist es.
Das ist es natürlich.
Wenn es Neurolektronen gibt,
dann ist es besser zu wissen.
Das ist es.
Ich bin nur ein Interessant.
Herr Professor, eine generelle Frage.
Ja?
Kann ich eine generelle Frage stellen?
Bitte.
Du hast gesagt, dass Medikament nicht in der Nutzung ist.
Aber wenn man die Pile anwesend hat,
hat man gesagt, dass man sie in der Nutzung benutzen kann.
Dann muss man sie in der Nutzung benutzen?
Ja, genau.
Ich benutze keine Medikament.
Dann muss man die Pile nicht als Medikament benutzen.
Ja?
Viele vergessen es.
Viele sagen es nicht.
Deswegen muss man sie in der Nutzung benutzen.
V.a. bei jungen Frauen.
Okay.
Ich habe es nicht in der Nutzung gesagt.
Okay, gibt es noch andere Fragen?
Oder etwas, was Sie anwesend haben?
Wenn Sie etwas anderes haben,
würde ich gerne wissen.
Vielen Dank, Herr Professor.
Wir danken für die Zeit.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen guten Abend.
Vielen Dank, Herr Professor.
Smit wir auch auch.
Ich wünsche Ihnen jetzt einen guten Abend, Herr Professor.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen guten Abend.
Ich wünsche Ihnen sich eine gute Zeit.
Vielen Dank.